the House Judiciary introduced an  amendment this is the latest who refer  to the President as Donald John Trump  that's what happened today yeah yeah  they added the job they out of the John  because that's where he writes most of  his tweets  [Applause]  and then flushes 15 yeah 15 to 18 times  yeah today on Twitter every day there's  a new thing today on Twitter and  president Trump bashed 16 year-old  climate activists Greta tunberg he went  after 16 year-old climate activists no  it's not that it is not the first time  Trump has criticized a teenager last  week he really gave it to a peak Budaj  edge so no no no no it got what it  deserved this is the holiday to give and  you gave more than enough it's come out  that Joe Biden was paying his female  staffers less money than their male  counterparts yeah yeah yeah once word  got out by and started doing much better  among Republicans  [Applause]